I guess I'm gonna start with the most
important question did you watch the
game of Thrones finale and what did you
think
Queen evanov don't tell me anything I
haven't seen one episode of Game of
Thrones
okay don't say a word I didn't watch
that sounds it dies uh-oh
I follow her around in the hallway going
Queen oh no she has today it's Sun she
she loves it I really love it it's good
I'm one of those people that catches up
like maybe four years after the decade
like just watch the shield last year the
entire series that's a great show
credible I haven't seen it we've been
warped in I did watch it and thanks so
he's [ __ ] amazing in it I was in
Moscow I'm on a junket so I couldn't
watch the finale so I literally I was
like no one look at me don't I didn't
want to turn my phone on like I just
and of course you know I so yeah I
watched it last night you just need to
watch the last last one and I have been
staying off of social media because I
don't want any spoilers the 2d action
episodes the the big fight in there then
what happens when I said he wasn't a
panic and there's a huge that was amazed
any time the poured episodes were like
just complete action episodes - no I
mean sure yeah and they were great they
were fantastic they were brilliant
action episodes I think she is a bit
sick of me with my fan theories and
Sophie's growing in age like in fact
she's such a vulnerable volatile
character in Dark Phoenix it's really
interesting to see her the ensue and
control so empowered and so in control
of her faculties
I sense oh she's amazing and actually I
wish you could see the whole time he's
like this no there's no spoilers there I
will say this Arya and Sansa are my
favorite parts of the series